it didn't sound weird when they said it
it just sounded when I said it anyways
um in the world of visual effects
Studios make use of hundreds of
different digital artists who are not
always right next to each other
sometimes they are half a world away at
each artist desk it is crucial to
maintain the consistency of the product
all through the process and that means
having a workstation monitor that
reliably displays images to the
untrained eye shred skin is just green
but to the artists it is a very specific
green and it has to remain that exact
green for each artist on each system the
HP dream color display designed with
DreamWorks Animation creates a color
space close to the one used in the
actual theatrical exhibition with a true
10-bit panel and offers color critical
management the monitor is not sensitive
to location or on-off cycling and can be
calibrated accurately and stapley making
sure that what you see is what you get
the display also has true 24 and 48 film
rate playback and was one of the first
LCD monitors to offer that in fact when
wet a digital called hewlett-packard
while working on the hobbit and asked if
they could modify their display to work
in 48 hewlett-packard response was it
already does that idiot anti-crime are
you serious for the development of the
HP dream color the Academy presents a
scientific and engineering award to John
Frederick Bob Meyers Carl Rashi and Tom
leanza team come on up
I would like to thank the academy for
this award on behalf of the entire dream
color team it is an honor to be
recognized for our contribution to this
industry we want to thank Greg staton
HP's dream college solution architect
greg has been the driving force behind
the dream color program for the past few
years and much of its success comes
directly from his efforts we want to
thank all the partners who contributed
to the first dream color monitor
DreamWorks Animation LG Display X right
portrait st micro cam tran and all the
studios that helped us with the product
requirements we'd also like to thank the
management teams of all the partners
evolved further ongoing support of this
program and of course the special thanks
to our wives and our families for their
love and support this is just the
beginning of our journey and we're
excited for the evolutions and
innovations to come thank
I really don't know what to say I'm a
color scientist the next time you meet
someone in the bar and they say there
are color scientist you can say oh I
knew one of them for me this was an
amazing project it took a lot out of me
and I wrote a lot of software and I'm
sure the guys out there that no software
would say geez I hope he knew more about
color than he knew about software but in
spite of that the project worked out
really well I want to thank everybody
for the support thank you so much for
this and special thanks to my wife and
family my wife Debra my daughter
Meredith and thanks again to Greg who's
really has been the spark plug behind
this whole thing but several years now
he's doing a fantastic job thank you all
just a huge thanks to all the people at
dreamworks animation for getting us here
and wonderful thanks to my wonderful
wife to ena thank you